no company wants to change unless it has
to change you know unless there is a
sense of urgency
into 20-minute leaders just sit back
really and learn from the
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside fam Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctek
foreign
was the co-founder and CEO of two
companies and led them to hundreds of
millions of dollars in revenues and sold
them to fortissimo PE and tell their
groups for tens of millions of dollars
and manage the NCR retalix Partners in
the Asia Pacific as well as variant
software in Australia and New Zealand
leading it successfully to 70 market
share in the last three years hem took
an active role in the proptech industry
as a board member and accelerators
invested in four startups and built a
reputation as the leading proptech
investor he is also serving as a board
member and consultant in several
startups as well
[Music]
[Applause]
Pam Rosen welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being with me
today how are you now I'm good thank you
very much for having me
I'm really excited for this episode then
um your journey is such a such an
interesting one I'm I you know I part of
my my research was trying to decide
where we're going to be spending a lot
of our time and and focus over these 20
minutes and I'm I have to say that I'm
still not totally sure because I often
find myself surprised but but I'm here
with my pen and paper to to learn from
you and get and get inspired over these
20 minutes tell me a little bit about
yourself because
and and we've we've already read your
your bio to to the audience here so
going through the different all such
different activities you've taken part
of right from so many different types of
roles to so many different Industries
can you connect the dots for me a little
bit as to who Pamela Zen is
yeah it's a good question I think that
uh um my career has actually demonstrate
the fact that I'm going uh after uh my
passion
and when I'm passionate about something
uh and you know something that might be
enthusiastic
I'll I will explore it and we'll follow
it and make sure that uh understand it
deeply and I think that this is
something also when I uh um you know
used to be in a certain place I always
after every six months looking for
something new that I can explore
and uh get to know about
and I think that that's the reason that
you can see that I uh was involved with
many fields and roles
eyes entrepreneur and as an exact
uh in the tech of communication in the
optical industry in the customer
experience industry uh and so on and in
the Cyber industry
yeah yeah I'm I'm really excited about
new things and that's that's the thing
you know uh there is people that really
like the routine and they like to go in
a certain path
uh which you know it's for myself I know
as well it can be easier and uh you know
less challenges but
I found it very boring and uh I'm really
one of the you know the people that
excited about new things new
technologies new people to meet new
people from different Industries and
different places in the world that would
make me excited and that's the reason
that my uh bio is so uh
um I would say diverse
right yeah
yeah and uh so traditional definitely
sounds easier but but it really
resonates that you're you're excited
about these challenges if you're looking
today at what at what you're doing and
what you get to interact with whether
it's with reality investment funds or or
any other organization that you're a
part of what what are you really excited
about today you know 2022 where are you
I'm excited first of all you know about
robtec because proptech itself is a it's
a new thing uh especially in uh in
Israel but also in uh in the US and in
the rest of the world so you know this
is definitely exciting me and and the
more it's sure it's uh new and
challenging uh the more I I get excited
so that the the challenge is the thing
that make me so uh uh
um uh grateful and happy that I'm part
of this journey second
I have to admit that you know the people
and and their Founders that I meet along
the way I just came back from New York I
told you about it before
we had some breakfast with these guys
and and you know I told them that they
feel so grateful to be part of this uh
purchase because I'm I'm meeting people
that are inspiring they're so smart
they're so uh enthusiastic about what
they're doing and about the way they're
going to change their the way we uh
we're living
and this is things that really make me
feel that I'm uh grateful and inspired
as well so for me uh people with with
vision and smart people that can execute
this uh this vision
uh consistently is something that really
make me excited
tell me a little bit about your decision
to focus at least a significant portion
of your time and cognitive energy on
proptech there's so many different
emerging Industries proptech is one that
I'm personally excited about as well and
we have some interesting companies also
out of Israel emerging in proptech
um tell me a little bit about this
industry as you've seen it evolve over
the last few years and and why this is
something specifically that you're that
you're putting your effort into
yeah I think that you know the first
thing is that the industry is very uh um
I would say in the beginning you know
it's very young and uh we can see over
the the last uh two or three years
companies that you know started from uh
prototype and and the idea and evolved
into uh now uh 56 till UH 60 million
dollar companies cup value I mean and
you can see how
this Founders actually took an idea and
developed it into uh something that
people are prepared to to pay for and
you know once you see that somebody is
willing to pay for your product you
understand there is a product and there
is a need in the market
so this is something that's really uh
attracts me to to be part of this
journey and protect itself when when I
first spoke about it with the
uh friends and and some family that
evolved in the real estate industry
I understand that the project uh it's
actually something that it was so so
early that people even couldn't Define
what is proctic you know property
technology but what exactly it means
which also make me uh feel that I want
to explore this and understand much
better and to be you know one of the the
people that you know the go-to people
that you uh go and ask what is proptech
and and what's the way that I see the
industry is developing
and even what's the uh the boundaries
for uh property and I have to say that
you know so far it's a
it's a broader
um I would say
a broad description of what is project
because it's really if you're talking
about the real estate world it's it's a
it's a huge World we're talking about
the biggest uh
uh uh asset class uh in value in the
world so if you think about real estate
and the way to define it it starts you
know from infrastructures
transactions uh building itself and and
many many other things that surrounding
it so it's really hard to Define it and
if it's hard to Define it it means that
it's even more challenging and once it's
more challenging I think it's part of
the reason that I'm uh into this
industry
right it's not just um going into an
emerging industry but it's actually
being able to help Define it and help
categorize the classified definition of
boundaries uh and there's sort of this
blue ocean that that's possible here and
so how how what were we at today you're
saying that we're still very early on we
I we are we do have some really
interesting startups that are that are
emerging I'm
personally involved with with Aviv and
gender but but I'm curious to hear a
little bit about you know what it what
are the different ways in which you see
this this industry booming now and how
is this going to impact the way that we
live our life in the next years in the
coming years yeah so so as I said before
I think it's a very young industry but
uh you mentioned Viv and and there is a
few others that are already uh unicorns
so we start seeing you know in the
recent years some companies that really
reach to uh the 1 billion uh dollar
company
uh but we still see uh most of them come
from the uh early stage
um and maybe start you know start
selling maybe a bit more there are I
would say tense
uh that's already reached to their 100
million mark value company
but we are in the early beginning and I
think that uh the more that we have uh
in Israel and abroad companies that
people who like you come from uh A200 or
81 units uh into the uh property
industry we can say that you know people
actually prefer the Tropic of the Cyber
on the syntek as well uh and we start
seeing this trend already you know I can
tell that in the last year I started
seeing people come from uh the unit yet
that you uh been in before in the Army
and uh I think that this is a good sign
I think that also we need to have uh
people from the uh Founders from the
logistics that actually understand the
build words much better than uh than
others uh I think that in the US it's a
bit more uh progress I would say uh I
see companies that are already uh uh
selling the product and they have
revenues of around the 20 30 billion
dollars which is which is a fair amount
for uh for startup
and I think that also a trend that I
um been able to to find out about in my
last trip to New York is that the real
estate company is the biggest one by the
way and and the real estate fund are
starting to
recruit ctOS and uh um you know once you
see ctOS as part of these companies
you understand that uh technology become
a strategic uh Initiative for these guys
they're willing to invest money
uh it's part of the CEO strategy and uh
little by little you'll start seeing uh
more and more companies that is part of
this journey and I think that this is a
great news for all of us I'm looking
forward to you know to
to meet these guys in this real estate
funding companies and make sure you know
that what I've what I've been told is
that's that's the trend and if it is we
are in a very good uh position to to
jump uh you know uh and and be able to
develop more and more companies
successful companies that come from the
property not only from cyber and shintek
I love it Reality Group and reality
Ventures within Reality Group let's dive
into that
so Reality Group is a a real estate fan
uh today's uh the biggest
group of real estate funds uh in Israel
I have to say that you know they did
this journey very uh they've been very
modest uh below the radar didn't try to
uh you know to shoot any uh everywhere
and and to have the shotgun approach
what they call
they was very uh professional of what
they're doing and
um and they become you know without
anybody noticed the biggest one in
Israel uh um they also have uh they have
six uh
um Equity Funds One debt fund and shield
funds in Germany
and reality proptech is actually uh the
way of writing a farm to be innovative
uh to be involved in the probe Tech
itself
and in the end of the day you know it
definitely can contribute to the top and
bottom line which is you know every
business just wanted to be part of his
uh
companion or what he's doing
but I say that it's it's include many
others elements and objectives other
than being profitable and and to
increase the uh the top line and and I
think that in the journey that we did in
the last uh
two years uh reality proved that uh you
know the the uh put the money with the
mouse is because we you can tell that uh
we have few startups that already uh
been uh part of our journey as a
relatively been a design pattern for
these startups we're investing in these
startups
um I I think that in general I would say
that part of the the role that I have if
I believe that I have a pocket of the
the mission that I have is to nurture
the ecosystem to make sure that the
ecosystems found their startups and real
estate players understand each other
helping each other supporting each other
because the journey is a is something
that both of them have to go through you
know but when you think about that in
the industry it's much easier to
it's updated the area at all to run a
starter but it's much easier or or less
harder to penetrate to a software
company with a cyber solution than to
penetrate as a as a company into a real
estate fund or real estate company with
a proptech solution you're talking about
two different uh usually two different
generation many different in the
mentality uh uh and and in the end of
the day you're looking on the real
estate industry as a very successful one
that uh it's profitable for many many
years so you know you're asking yourself
and I'm asking also myself and my
friends
why to change you know you have to make
sure that you you
um find a sense of urgency in his
company and and need to change the urge
to change otherwise they won't purchase
your uh product
and on the other hand you understand
that these companies are very successful
so you really have to to be laser
focused of what you're doing and I think
that my role has helped all the these
sides around the table understand uh
each other and make sure that till the
end of the day it will be a win-win
situation for all of them
and is it natural for a such a you know
you know when you're looking at
consistent results and you know real
estate has been relatively you know good
investment and and considered a pretty
long-term one and here you're
introducing venture capital and you're
introducing startups regardless of
whatever industry they're in they're
venture-backed startups which means they
go big or go home right so how how are
you how how do you find the balance with
this type of mentality obviously there's
ways to de-risk but still it's a VC
company so there's risk how do you
balance that with a larger you know sort
of global mindset of what real estate
represents
yeah so you know first of all as I said
before uh no company wants to change
unless it has to change you know unless
there is a sense of urgency
so I think that the kovid coveted
pandemic was uh part of you know a sense
of urgency that companies in the real
estate uh industry uh
uh understand that they have to to do
the changes in order to be you know to
stay in the business and be profitable
again
uh but I think it's you know as an Eddie
company and and also in profit you have
to find day after day what exactly the
things that make
uh um this real estate companies failed
that they need to change and they need
to adopt Your solution because it can
break some benefits that they wasn't uh
aware about before or wasn't able to
uh to observe in the past so uh it's
it's a it's a daily uh challenge that
you know me you know and mainly the
startup by themselves have to face and
have to to make sure that they can uh
can find what they find what the points
that uh the real estate companies need
to change in
um and also you know on the other hand I
have to to
um work closely with the real estate
developers and landlords and property
managers
and to make sure that they understand
the Journey of a startup is a lamp
journey and they have to support them uh
and not try to observe of the benefits
of getting all the benefits at once
uh and uh if they you know as much as
they will cooperate the startup will be
successful so it's it's tied together so
um I think that as I said before once
you have a CTO in these companies it's
definitely changed the way that uh the
real estate companies looking on
startups and and let them uh you know
get into their business
and and I'm not you know on any on any
way I'm not uh downgrading the uh the
fear and uh concern that the real estate
guys have these guys are running a very
successful business
on the other hand with you know with low
margins and they don't want to lose
their business it's it's really
understandable uh what they're trying to
achieve and hence we have to make sure
that once we provide a solution it's a
working solution that not jeopardize
their Core Business
and at the end of the day all the the
sites that involve our benefits
I love it tell me about long-term vision
where do you see your you know vision
for prop Tech vision for reality
Ventures event for for your own Journey
talk to me about what's keeping you up
at night about this journey
yeah it's a big question uh so let's try
this is set to divide it so so for the
proptech I think that uh
my vision is that you know as as the
same Revolution that we have with the uh
fintech and automobile the 10 15 years
ago nobody believed that uh uh part of
uh the digital uh bank will be part of
our life as well as Tesla or other
automobile
companies you know that drive by itself
or even uh semi-autonomic uh and even
you know the the cars the one who don't
have Tesla can feel that if you compare
to the cars that we have 20 years ago 30
years ago it's uncomparable
I just recalled you know my wife uh
called me when I was traveling and said
you know there is uh like 20 alarms at
once in the car uh that's saying they
know that any system is not working and
you think about it you're saying yeah
it's the battery but when you think it
deeply you understand that there's so
many systems in the car now depend on
electricity and on uh you know our
digital systems as well
and uh if you're not uh uh part of uh
you know uh these companies you don't
know how to solve the uh the problem so
I think the same the same thing is going
to happen and in property I think that
we're going to involve digital Solutions
uh as part of uh at the beginning part
of uh I would say the fair share of real
estate you know not exactly the the core
uh Solutions but you know in
transactions uh uh in in
um everything that is not uh actually
changing the way that we build the
building will will change dramatically
in the next uh five years
and I believe that in the next thing is
we'll see also a big change in the core
of the the real estate uh industry of
the way that we will be building
buildings the way that we renovating and
so on
uh um the same as we we saw in other
industry I think that for a reality
project
uh part of this
I believe it will be part of this
journey as I said before I I see I our
role as uh the one who have to nurture
the ecosystem to to to become a Melting
Pot for this ecosystem to make sure that
uh real estate companies and startups
are talking in the same language
understand each other and flourish
together
uh and I believe that in uh
I would say four or five years would
definitely will be it it will be there I
can see the purpose uh in the last two
or three years and I believe that it
will be the same for the for the next
year's uh as well
uh and for myself I just want to be in a
position to be part of it that's it
because I really believe in this uh area
and I truly enjoy being it with this
amazing entrepreneurs and also with the
smart real estate guys that know how to
do business
I love it sounds a like a great vision
on both fronts and and I really
appreciate not only these 20 minutes
which I very much do because I know how
busy you are but but really
um the the way that you live your career
the way you connect the dots and taking
us back to the beginning of the
conversation talking about passion and
talking about uh embracing challenges
and new opportunities as the most
exciting piece of this puzzle and it's
very evident you know throughout your
career how you've been
um able and and willing to to make these
Transitions and leaps of faith and
obviously not with proptech and I
imagine with many more years there will
be more
also newer industries that will pop up
that that will pique your interest so
thank you for that inspiration wishing
you best of luck with with reality
Ventures and I look forward to keeping
in touch and thank you thank you very
much it was a pleasure thank you
thank you